[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
this is rich bounty live here for the
first time what are you waiting why you
don't take that ball ninety-two hey that
sounds gone is your shirt like soaked
with tears Oh Caleb took a week to play
blitz bounty okay get some kid oh yeah I
mean sounds like a fun time so as you
see my Mac scuffle yeah so I actually
beat Jonathan really easily the easiest
match of my life miss funneling in front
like a hundred viewers I should try it
sometime Oh
congratulations I guess I'm really happy
for you
I suppose success is something I'm only
ever going to know vicariously yeah well
I mean success is all I've ever really
known hard for me to kind of relate to
what you're going but where do you set
up another match for you anyways should
be fine blitz bounty round to michael
Pugachev coming up this june you're
putting 36 bucks on the line into
Powerball tickets maybe they'll oh honey
hey wait I don't really want to do this
[Music]
yes
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for blitz bounty - the very second
the second ever blitz bounty event
featuring Dennis LaRue my name is Ben
Simon I'm here with Grandmaster
Alexander Lenny Minh for one of the most
serious events he's ever been a part of
no doubt Alex welcome to the show
you have no idea what you're getting
yourself into and I hope you enjoy your
stay
yeah thank you know it should be fun I'm
looking forward to it very much so
so we've witnessed an evolution of blitz
bounty over the years it started with
Mike comer years ago where we would
record videos of him playing small
children and he had five blitz bounties
I believe and all but one he was
victorious
Dennis LaRue has attempted thus far to
follow in Mike's footsteps with his
version of blitz bounty it's newer its
flashier and it's live but he hasn't had
the same success thus far last time we
saw you for blitz bounty number one he
lost to Jacob Sanders 15 years old
player and this was not Mike comer
versus a child this was two players of
similar ratings similar strengths going
head-to-head in a blitz match not really
the old bounty of Mike comers game but a
match best of four blitz games game in
five the winner when you hit two and a
half if it's tied two and two they go to
a an Armageddon now this is not gambling
Mike comer would want us to tell you
that the grand tradition of blitz bounty
it's not gambling because only the
Challenger puts out the bounty on his
own head it's kind of strange how that
happens but Dennis LaRue for this event
I understand has put up a very generous
prize fund he's bought two Powerball
tickets at the behest of Caleb identity
and he's also put up thirty-six dollars
of his own money and this is important
because he's low on funds right now
thirty-six dollars in case you're
curious is the prize fund for a victory
in
Friday action quads so this is at least
as glorious as winning our Friday night
event because it'll be missing it starts
at 7:00 anyway I want to tell you a
little bit about our players in this
matchup first I want to talk about
Dennis LaRue
now a lot of people around here and know
about Dennis LaRue formerly the
instructor of tactics time here at the
club and now a little bit of a YouTube
celebrity he's a chess instructor he's a
part of management here at the club and
he basically helps out a lot with the
goings-on here around this famous chess
club
Dennis LaRue 37 years old originally
from California the smoggy part of
California he would like me to say and
he is rated 1451 USCF regular and
unfortunately for him his blitzes a 1263
his opponent is michael pugachev for
participating in his very first blitz
bounty event and there he is the
Terminator himself he wears his
sunglasses at night well it's getting to
be night a nice little Starbucks drinks
there that will fill you up for a fierce
competition against Dennis LaRue he has
14 years old his family is from Ukraine
his parents are Ukrainian and he has
lived here though in st. Louis his
entire life he's a hockey player and you
know given the stakes in the Stanley Cup
right now maybe he's probably a blues
fan as well but I'm not sure about that
don't want to insult him if he's go for
the Bruins but he's ready I asked him
what his plan was for Dennis LaRue and
he said to win you know it's kind of a
lame question it baguettes a lame answer
but it's true alex is yeah true and I
like why his Dennis Lew I asked him what
his plan was and what did he say Alex to
win yeah basically he was like I don't
want to make any blunders and I got to
play fast and you know it's as I I
believe there's still yeah five-minute
time control sudden-death they're in
good spirits now but one of them is
gonna be crushed later on your arbiter
is Nick risco and his first high-profile
event here on the YouTube channel man
this is up there with us champs no doubt
to 1500 players giving it their all in
some blitz action and they are about to
start in about 30 seconds I understand
LaRue's got his phone in the room that's
highly suspect because this is a rated
blitz match this is USCF rated blitz
it's not fidei I think it's starting it
off though oh okay thank goodness you
got to get it out of there have those
guys been wanded by the way I think it's
kind of hard to a computer cheating
blitz though just not enough time here
let me check let me check my engine here
I got some stock fish running oh darn I
flagged on move eight and there is Nick
reading his holy scripture the USCF
rulebook in the moment here will be
started with this fierce competition now
remember in the Mike comer days it was
if the Challenger if you will that would
be puka Jeff in this case if he won just
one game draws don't count if he won one
game he gets the bounty LaRue is more
evenly matched LaRue says no you got to
beat me in a blitz match so we are going
to see what happens best of four blitz
game in five we certainly thank you for
joining us here on YouTube exclusively
on YouTube and I've got the YouTube chat
open right now
Joe Kyle thank you for joining us when
will Ben Simon be doing a bounty well
we'll have to see about that joke al not
anytime soon alright the game is
underway and there we at nice look there
at the board in your lower right corner
with this alright alright what's going
on so far Alex so we have uh Sicilian a
close Sicilian baggage office playing
white and they're playing close Sicilian
as far as I could see he's expanding in
the with a 4 d 3 so it seems like
they're both pretty familiar with the
opening but right now we're not ok now
we got some more moves so black is
playing actually a very harmonious set
up what nygean
and then maybe either d6 35 and why does
you know potentially hoping for King
side attacks so both players are
familiar so far with the theory they're
playing very logical high level games so
far they're both playing
wouldn't have known that there are 1500
players right they're both playing like
a grandmaster so far I can't believe it
well you know these players they do book
up a little bit and I am no match for
either one of them in the openings
Department despite being around the same
rating mm-hmm
so they've they've castled now yeah so
there's this board is a bit slow when it
comes to giving us moves but let's see
if we can glance it at the live board
what do you say yeah that's let's do
that actually yeah yeah so from what I
could see in a white expanded would be
five but then black got his Knight to f5
and he's controlling the d4 square and
now blacks idea will be to place
something like f6 challenging that one
on e5 and I would say position is
dynamically equal and now we do get we
do have all these moves on the board
both are roughly equal on the clock you
know both have around four minutes left
and our progress over stinking I going
for g4 but that move is a bit risky you
know because now black and play Knight
h4 or 94 and potentially that King might
be a bit weekend let's see where he go
okay he played marriage four which is
probably a good move and I don't think
you can take and then go g5 because the
queen is not gonna get trapped I don't
think so so far it looks good for Dennis
LaRue this position but of course still
playing you fight here and you mentioned
that while white is having a thing here
Knight takes Knight on h4 Queen takes
and then g5 to try to trap the Queen
what does the Queen do back to h5
probably just play h6 and then try to
undermine the board on on g5 in that
case so pugachev is still no he played a
move Bishop d2 so but that's very risky
because now you can take on G to remove
that Bishop from g2 and that's like one
of their very important pieces that
covers the king and that's what Dennis
LaRue does so far dennis is playing
excellent chess now I think you should
play f6 open up the Kings side and then
play b6 Bishop e7
put that bishop on this very nice
diagonal long diagonal and put pressure
on that shivery King on jitsu I think
black is clearly better in this position
good start here for Denis then by
yourself Dennis played b6 first and now
I think if I was white I'll play g5 and
maybe try to shut down their six idea
although that does give their five
squares so either way I think black is
still better all right baggage office
going bishop you won which makes a lot
of sense he's trying to go Bishop h4 put
pressure on the Queen so far they're
both playing decent chests and now black
played a6 which seems to be like a loss
of time a wide broadening the bishop on
h4 and now white will probably bring the
Queen into the King set as well now I
think why does stabilize the now I think
white is doing much better I think he
had to blare six you know before playing
b6 that is Dennis now the time he's also
catching up on time and I think baggage
office his chances are improving now if
I was white I would probably go Queenie
one Bishop f6 and a 10 Queen h4 and
[Music]
Pugachev looks like he's gonna go oh
he's going Bishop g3 I would have
definitely gone initiative six tried to
get a pawn watch porn on f6 but yeah now
I think black is better again so Bishop
g3 seems a bit inaccurate so he's going
for h4 but that seems too slow and
anyway I think you can play f6
challenging him so this board is still
not giving us anything by black 24 and
but that might be premature because now
white got the 4-square control maybe
again I think f6 should have been played
at some point now again I like white
because now White has a straight forward
attacking plan h5 rook h1 and so on
okay black is probably gonna go 97 which
is a good move trying to go 95 93 and
trying to activate the night
I'd like to step in and say right now
that we are having some resolution
issues for those of you watching us
online right now and have no fear we
will be uploading this match and full HD
after it after it concludes this evening
so Dennis went for an interesting
decision but I don't think that's was
very good I think he should have played
95 93 and brought the knight in the game
because here the knight on e7 is very
restricted and now I think White has a
free hand in his attack with the rope h1
to h4 now I think white is again in very
much control he book that Shah was
reaching for his H pawn thinking about
taking I would play rook h1 here and
then Bishop h4 and try to start an
attack bring that Bishop back to h4 oh
wow is he gonna go a5
oh I think that's just a mistake because
that that's just not safe there are more
attackers and defenders there so I think
a5 is a very big mistake but they're
getting low on time and then it's Leroux
correctly took the porn and now after
pawn takes pawn takes black will just be
a component with a much better game so
pocket roaches made a very huge mistake
f5 which lets that night in the game and
maybe he just miscounted the pieces and
now white is close to losing and now
he's also getting low on time and you
know he better move quickly here because
he's reading right running a long time
and there's no delay in no increment
here Alex I mean I think this is not I
don't like this time control at all I
mean it leaves too much up to time it's
all time but that's what these guys
wanted to play yeah I think it's better
if it splits you know with let's say
three two or something you know what do
these sounds a little increment that way
there's no flagging in a dead drawn
position but okay in this case I think
it won't be much of a factor here black
is out playing white positionally
because f5 this one very bad move really
cost
Pugachev i mean unless he finds a
miracle comeback Houdini act a white
will lose this game
and he's thinking along ok g5 is
probably good practical try but yeah
it's not very looking very good and now
black is playing correctly 95 bringing
light in the game the night goes 3 3 and
he's playing it quickly so so far
Dennis's strategy is working well
playing quickly and not blundering you
know so far I'm impressed
Dennis and I we play a lot of blitz
together poopy Jeff and I not so much
but one thing I've seen from Dennis he
he is beating me in every blitz game we
play we're playing three-two every blitz
game he has the upper hand and he blows
a lot of them near the end in time
pressure now the difference here is he's
significantly up in time yeah but whilst
we'll see here because that that's where
that lower blitz rating comes from for
dennis is blundering in time pressure
and it's very frequent yeah and here
block could just take on e5 because the
knight on the three spinned and that
pawns captured by Lee he goes for it he
finds it so far Genesis playing very
precisely now rook takes e5 because you
cannot take o tonight because knight is
pinned or you can do Knight text but
rook takes is much better but he got a
play quicker 23 or now you know naruki 3
is probably good rook e8 is a very good
move bringing the last piece in the game
ok he once goes for check now rookie 4
no now well okay if you take the rook I
guess Quincy to check is his idea which
is winning yes and he finds it and now
Queen takes h1 he has to play all he
takes the knight which is also probably
winning and now white is really running
very low on time rock h4 - only seven
seconds left for Michael and then Knight
62 and then rook e1 is checkmate in soo
now rook e1 is checkmate in one rookie
one maiden won and he finds it and he
wins the first game and very clutch
performance here by Denis LaRue you know
and the big difference was that f5 move
that very big lemon which left the point
unprotected and also more important
it helped at night on e7 which was
restricted by the pawn on e4 get in the
game it's all about peace activity and
like I always tell all my students and
I've done lectures on this team my
greatest losses it's now on YouTube
this activity is a very important factor
and f5 was very costly move and
eventually after that LaRue never really
let go of his initiative and won a very
nice game very good start for for Denis
just like what the doctor ordered
remember it's best of four and there you
see it Denis LaRue one to nothing to
start Alex it's nice of you to cite my
greatest losses you know you can learn a
lot from those yes definitely yeah I
definitely very much recommend those
videos they're all on YouTube now very
instructive stuff in my opinion all
right so I guess we don't have anything
live here but not yet we're gonna be
starting the second round
I understand momentarily perhaps just a
minute or two break for these players
they're gonna just buzz right through
here like I said thank you for joining
us here in the YouTube chat I am looking
at your comments rarely Pokemon rarely
pokemon is in the chat and he says my
screen is blurry like I said we'll be
uploading the full HD version right
after this show has concluded he says
Michael is my friend well a better way
to be here than the root for your friend
yeah definitely
Aditya Chandra he is in here hello
Aditya and Alexei Alexei a coach here in
the st. Louis area coach of many kids in
the area he is cheering for Michael
Pugachev I say that the world is mostly
in fubá Jeb's corner does this affect
you Alex have you ever been an emotional
favorite or at an emotional disadvantage
when it comes to the public cheering you
on
oh I mean I don't remember I mean it
goes both ways the drill depends a lot
on whom I'm playing but no not not
really I don't kind of let it go it's
just focused on my game I have to say
that while getting ready
bored too and you know how much we'll
look at our digital board but okay
is that round one though it might be a
yellow is this a little close that one
close that little go up to that arrow
and click it this one yeah there's a
second round there we go it was placing
the wrong one anyway we'll be watching
this game no matter what everyone and I
gotta tell you that trash talk is
allowed in this match believe it or not
both players have agreed that they can
trash talk during this match
it is a blitz bounty staple but I would
imagine that not one word has been
exchanged between the two of them how it
usually goes with blitz bounty as they
say we're gonna trash talk we're gonna
trash talk and then they don't yeah we
were gonna have a our correspondent
Perry Coulson up in the tournament hall
this evening as our trash talk
stenographer
unfortunately Perry's a little under the
weather this evening so hopefully they
don't trash-talk so we don't miss
anything here we go we're under way a
game - Dennis LaRue up by one well they
were playing an Italian game so far gqo
piano and baggage office so far they're
playing the main line and white played
us went for the slow gioco piano slow
setup and let's see what Dennis plays 92
now I love the gioco piano that's
probably the most common opening amongst
beginner players with yep mm-hmm
well kind of an but it's also becoming
one of the most popular the top level as
well as early kind of made it a little
bit more popular as you started winning
games in it and now it's become very
popular the reason is there's pawns
don't get exchanged and the positions
are very hard for the computer to get a
grasp on and there are a lot of very
deep salties and for top level games you
know they want to play games where
things don't fizzle out very quickly and
where it's more a matter of
understanding and out playing people
based on nuances and details and you
know that's how top players are I mean
they want to take advantage of these
things and so far both players are
playing very logical chess
no real mistakes for either
side they're both playing yeah and which
takes c6 is I think a good move you know
potentially doubling these spawns and
now white will prepare from before and
Bishop Queen b3 potentially so so far
both sides are playing pretty well
they're definitely they've definitely
proved that they know their theory in
the first two games they definitely know
the theory so they have some fundamental
knowledge and then it just comes down to
how quickly they would see some tactics
alright so pugachov goes for a quick
Knight g4 which you know probably could
easily be met with 93 or Bishop e3 so
but it's not really a mistake but
probably it's a little premature I
wouldn't play it but it's not really a
big deal and white with rookie - well
this move is a bit risky because now you
have to consider up takes f3 sacrifice
and black and by for initiative I'm not
sure if it's so good here but it worked
except three with the idea G takes f
three open the King up yes and then just
Knight of six back and then just playing
for initiative although I'm not quite
sure how good it is here but certainly
something to consider but more likely it
doesn't work so yeah black played a5
trying to prevent before but that's
probably nothing so special so rookie 2
was played and then a 5h 3 9 of 6 yeah
so
you know still nothing that much is
happening and pugachov again is spending
quite a lot of time trying to figure it
out but they both seem like actually
pretty decent blitz players for what I
could tell they seem like players with
some experience Michael pugachev I
remember years ago when I was recording
the kids classes on Sundays he was the
kid in there he was the superstar you
know he it was curious for a while I was
like why is he still coming to this
class because the the rest of the class
was just seemed light-years behind him
yeah but he's really stepped up his game
and his uh amongst the scholastic
players in the area he's one of the best
mm-hmm yeah so it goes to show that yeah
he definitely has a lot of ability
definitely he's up there
Dennis he's his arms suspended in
quantum indecision there we go Bishop
takes well now I think c4 yeah good move
you know challenging the center and so
far I really like Dennis display I mean
no blunders quick play convincing you
know stick to his plans very convincing
play bye bye Dennis so far and I think
white is better now after Knight 64 and
then Queen b3 and piling up pressure on
e6 in fact it's very hard for Black team
and save the pawns so somewhere few
moves back pugachov made a mistake and
he took her tonight he's playing very
well like he's making all the right
decisions Queen d7 and now Queen b3
would be very strong
if he finds Queen b3 he definitely
deserves to not only win this game but
probably the match as well if he's
finding you know such moves Queen b3 I
mean that guarantees you a pawn does it
not probably yes I mean if any founder
and he's playing you know he's truly
playing spectacular just so far in this
tournament I mean really in very good
form today seeing the ideas of tactical
putting pressure on his opponent just
playing very sharp chess now black
probably needs to play d5 I'd end up
one bringing last piece in the game he
file opens up and there's gonna be a lot
of pressure so black played d5 which is
as good as anything but now if you take
an employer he won I think white is
doing very well and so he took which is
good and now if he takes with anything
but the poor then the pawn on e6 hangs
so he took what's gonna take with the
porn in Outlook AE one getting that last
piece in the game attacking the knight
on e7 it's a very strong idea but the
only thing is Denis is taking a little
but maybe sometimes too much time on
very straightforward decisions you
should play a little quicker probably
right now he could have been like
potentially half a minute to a minute
that we had in the clock given his good
position but you know the time station
gives black some fighting chance
okay so Knight g6 now night night of
five I think is good trying to exchange
those Knights on e7 the problem for
black is the rook on a7 is out of play
right now it's a dynamically misplaced
piece so that's why white has a lot of
initiative why did that rook go to a 7
in the first place mister takes a 7
happened at some point in Brooke had to
correct right okay yeah I do recall and
he played an out of five so once again
he's playing his plea he's playing very
good chess truly very good shots like I
mean even if this was not a blitz game
but it's over the board game I mean
longer time control I don't think white
would have been able to play better it's
really you know very high quality blitz
game just putting pressure move after
move just you know I'm very impressed
so black blitz c-54 now 9797 is very
powerful exchanging the the Knights and
then the Rope comes in and he and he'll
find it I think I think he finds it yes
Wow
just incredible but the only problem is
the time you know as long as he manages
the time you know that's gonna be the
key and now this was gonna be very bad
because now either Knight a5 or 96 will
come next and black is really you know
very close to just going down those
rooks on the seventh rank that's where
they want to be
that's dreamland for white and it looks
like Denis 96 now 96 very powerful move
yes very good
playing very quickly Denis very nice
yeah look up 7 only move he has to play
it quickly he has to play quickly I mean
he's getting very long time painfully
long time and then you can you know do a
lot of good things maybe takes and then
Queen b5 take some quincy to just you
know a very good choice you know the
fact that there's a choice there's no
immediate knock out might be tough for
Denis a little bit oh don't take on d5
please don't take on d5 Knight 65 then
don't hang the Queen please don't hang
the Queen night of 4 very good that's
much better yes now blacks should play
Queen of 5 ok you played c4 now Queen c2
Queen c2 Queen g6 Quincy one's also fine
but now they're now it's gonna be a very
big time scramble okay now you know
Queen c2 that's why was better it knows
to stop Queen a5 now Queen d4 centralize
the Queen and rookie 5 and okay 92 now
94 now pugachov has a little initiative
still white is better rook F 1 now the
time is catching up and now Pugachev's
playing good chess quickly rook in the
game Queen f3 rook f6 now rook f6 yes
Queen g4 or Queen III and now it's gonna
be really a time scramble whoever
whoever just plays quicker we
but LaRue has to dennis has to speed up
they both have to speed up they have 20
seconds they gotta just play moves at
this point
stop thinking right you just gotta move
it just got a wolf via rookie one rookie
one quicker quicker quicker guys each
second is he ate meat Queen he ate meat
rounded oh that's painful for oh my god
good chef it became such a good fight
but he needed to block the file with 96
oh and he looks to Janice LaRue
look at him confidently sipping his
beverage and look up dejected and now
he's gonna have to win two games and
demand you know just to get some reading
but if anyone can do it it's him you
know I think he's a very good fighter
but yeah he looks dejected man Dennis
LaRue is looking to run roughshod over
Michael Pugachev he wants Redemption he
this is his series and he was
embarrassed last time and he's angry now
and when you play blitz bounty angry man
anything is possible
good stuff from Dennis LaRussa yeah very
good game I mean sure I mean it wasn't
perfect but I mean I think overall he is
playing clearly much better chess and
considering it's blitz I mean I'm
actually very impressed with the quality
of these games considering it's five
minutes 1,500 level I would say you know
they're playing much more closer to like
two thousand and fifteen hundred level
that is a shining endorsement coming
from you well if you're just joining us
welcome to something special this is
blitz bounty to LaRue versus pugachev
I'm Ben Simon joined along with
Grandmaster Alexander Linderman and we
are halfway home in a best of four game
in five blitz series it's rated by the
way and trash talk is encouraged but
while we don't have a way to listen to
the trash talk now these players are
very respectful upstairs so I don't
think we're missing anything right now
LaRue leads to nothing if Pugachev can
hope to win he has to clinch the next
two games a draw won't do it win the
next two and then go to an Armageddon
five minutes versus four minutes to
settle the score
so by the way once again we are
broadcasting in a in a lower than
standard def resolution right now so do
not worry we will upload the full HD
broadcast after the conclusion of
tonight's show but thank you for joining
us if you have any questions for myself
or Alex be sure to hit us up in the chat
I do have it open and right now it's a
conversation between two people they're
entertaining so wonder what they're
doing up in the terminal huh oh we're
getting ready for Game three
I suppose I saw was white and here's the
term he's focused you know he's he's
angry now I God could tell he he wants
that that win most recently you know
Hikaru Nakamura came to the board here
in st. Louis in sunglasses do you feel
like this is an advantage or a
disadvantage you can't see with
sunglasses
oh I don't know I mean I guess it's just
super vent you know a opponent from like
you know seeing what you you know you
think can't track the so now which one
is oh yeah no this is this one we
already did yeah it's this one yeah
there we go the Dutch and you know
credit goes to you know Dennis LaRue
he's playing the Dutch despite the fact
that he only needs a draw normally
that's an opening you play when you need
the win but it's probably an opening he
knows best and he's playing like a stone
wall kind of Dutch and I think white got
a better of it because he was able to
get a bishop from c1 into the game
normally in the stone wall Dutch you
want Y to still have the bishop on c1 so
I think why definitely got the better
version now pugachov to his credit he
knows both d4 and e4 he can play both
and that's already showing a lot of
versatility at that level normally at
this level we see people just playing
one opening all the time but he actually
is quite versatile and he definitely
shows quite a lot of understanding of
the structures so once again we see
these both of these players very much
proficient in their openings but g6 I
don't like that move I think he should
have played 94 trying to exchange the
Knights and the bishops and just
developed now he created more weaknesses
which okay it's not the end of the world
but now he has to play rook e8 quickly
ruk f7 would be bad because then the 95
our Knight g5 would come dropping so
it's now pugachov is playing quickly and
confidently he needs to he needs to win
only a win does it and now 95 so now 97
so good move try to get rid of that
night I think blacks fine I mean he got
his solid setup but I think white is ok
2 and a 4 you know
pugachov is reaching out to player 4
that would be actually a mistake I think
because then night 65 followed by 94 and
an admission on h6 will be trapped so I
don't think he sees that I'm wondering
if Danis level will see it okay so you
bite h4 oh wow very ambitious he is
going all in all in you say all in oh
now I think you should take on e5 and go
94 okay he goes Knight e4 this I'm not
so sure because maybe h5 now continuing
but okay it's still it's still very much
a very complex position so it's hard to
say whether one side is better or not
here but all I can say it's looking it's
boiling to become a very very sharp
fight
that Bishop on h6 should black be
worried about that long-term can
anything join up with it well this rf8
potentially neutralizes it and for now
the bishop on h6 action the blocks the
attacks so I'm not sure if it's such a
big deal now you have to take with the
f1 because deep 1de would be a huge
blunder allowing Bishop c4 check and
then King h8 knight of seven and game
over so you have to take either the
knight on e4 or you can do 965
intermediate move but you cannot do d
takes e4 here and he correctly takes
with F pawn so Leroux is on top of his
tactics today Denis is on top of his
tactics today so now White has to move
well if he takes bishop takes e4 which
would be very interesting if De Quincey
4 but the problem is then there's 965
intermediate the bishop takes e4 Knight
65 would happen intermediate so Y just
went back but now you can just take any
five and go Bishop before check and win
the pawn on e5 so now black is doing
quite well here and indeed you know
black is doing quite well let's see how
he will play this okay so he give the
check first and now he king will have to
go ref one then Knight takes e5 so once
again dennis is in control
king of one night 65 he goes King D one
that's even more dangerous because then
the King can potentially be attacked and
then you know probably black will pick
up the porn yeah very good stuff by
block now he's up a porn and white just
has to hope for you know some kind of an
attack for some kind of counter play you
said
hope for some kind of attack some kind
of kind of like counter play there's not
much concrete here for white is there
yeah there was not I mean white is just
worse here so he tries to talk to Bishop
but now Bishop f8 would be fine no
trying to neutralize the bishop on h6
Bishop to any other square would be fine
as well he plays Bishop f8 probably
that's what he's looking at but he's
hesitating
alright there you go he ends up going
for Bishop d6 I would have preferred the
ship f8 to keep an option of d4 opening
up the game but black is still in
control of course white ride the ship g5
but still there's white is just much
worse down upon
okay so this should be seven Bishop f4
yep I have to move the rock rocker five
maybe four rocky six
now look at six yeah so I mean I think
black did not play it perfectly but
again he is staying away from the very
big miscues very big blunders so black
is still very much doing well here so
why does not win the trade because he's
down material now I think t4 might
already be time for g4 opening up the
game for the king and potentially
threatening g3 and he goes and he's
gonna go for it
brave man Dennis Larew
just on top of all the ideas once again
you know his form today is is very much
on top Bishop c4 Bishop e6 has to be
played I think although Bishop e6
there's Bishop g5 okay well maybe
actually I spoke too soon maybe it's
actually was a bit risky to go t4
because it does give white someplace so
maybe actually it looked very tempting
but maybe it was actually not the
absolute best but I still like blacks
chances after Bishop e6 but he's
probably not so sure here he's spending
a lot of time that's the only thing
that's hurting okay he's staying away
from all the immediate tactics okay King
e8 yeah and now the game is getting very
sharp if you if you take sunny for then
Detex III will be discovered check so
now pugachov is Michael is thinking eg
Queen takes d4 Queen takes d4 think is a
good move just take the pawn with check
here can't be too bad
threatening grouped X of 2
you know now Kings see one room takes of
two so King you one maybe but then
Bishop g4 he's if he's gonna go Queen
did he's gonna walk King see one rook
takes off to look takes up to now take
that pawn enough to attack the Queen you
know definitely I don't see a problem
with that he's taking a lot of time
though God come on Dennis you gotta play
quicker it's you're not seeing that move
or is he looking for something better
but he needs to move Dennis you need to
move
okay he finally sees it come on Dennis
don't hesitate don't overthink just play
now he has 40 seconds so White's main
hope is the time and the fact that it's
still a little bit complicated now I
think white needs to play Queen b3 you
got to stay around that B pawn yeah
Queen b3 I have to stare on the B port
otherwise it'll be made yeah Queen b3 is
a good move also preparing Bishop e3
potential tactics so now it's down to
the wire
both players have 40 seconds they gotta
play quickly they gotta play very
quickly here and they're both taking a
lot of time they're very unsure this
rough six I think it's a good move so
much complications but Dennis you have
to move Dennis you gotta move now
oh my gosh listen 20 seconds so he's
going for some c4 but now Bishop e3
there should be three I think he missed
that there should be three wins material
attacks the Queen and the rook Booker
Chavez not seeing it I think Michael
he's blinking b1 saving the king which
also makes a lot of sense practically
but come on you gotta play quick come on
Dennis rook g8 King 8su now then
threatening b5 it's gonna go down to the
wire but I predict white will win this
on time because he's taking too long
he is playing two seconds five seconds
each move now I just needs to play very
quickly and finally I he now he won the
Queen and then yeah and now you've won
on time so that's it
two to one Dennis slips up for the first
time and so we are going to Game four
can Michael Pugachev win this fourth
game and force and Armageddon or with
only a draw
Dennis LaRue will win in Game four it's
all on the line coming up next Alex yeah
it is um no it again gives some trick
yeah did Dennis you know I think he was
playing well once again but he was just
taking too much time he's like
hesitating too much not trusting himself
just maybe a bit nervous because he's
about to put the match away and just
doubting himself too much just
spending too much time in general of the
rulers you don't want to spend more than
half your remaining time on one move
almost ever and that's exactly what he
was doing when you had 40 seconds he was
spending 20 seconds a move when he had
10 seconds he was spending 5 6 seconds a
move you just cannot afford to do it and
blitz or in any time control for that
matter it's interesting I hadn't heard
of put into words like that before
yeah and in general what I couldn't
recommend my students is avoid spending
even more than 25% of the of the time
remaining on any move unless it's like
super critical like maybe once or twice
during game but in general you want to
make sure you play you know kind of
based on how much time you have of
course you want to spend more if it's a
critical position but at the same time
you gotta trust yourself sometimes and
play more intuitively you can't possibly
pretty perfect move every time I'm not
sure exactly how the rest period is
timed out it would be a question for our
arbiter Nick risco but right after the
game was over in the seat was vacant you
saw Dennis Liu get up and go around and
sit immediately down he wants to forget
that Laskin yes he didn't like slip-ups
and
Pugachev not too far behind them but it
looks like LaRue is intently focused
okay well now maybe he's going to get
some more introduced or something before
the games today the demeanors of both of
these players were markedly different
michael was upstairs on the ground floor
or which is downstairs from the
tournament hall and he was sitting on
that sofa in our front area and he was
just as chill as a cucumber and he was
happy to answer questions about the
match and about his life and his chess
whereas Dennis was in the basement
pacing back and forth
brooding very intense thinking about
this game and you're wondering is this a
good thing or a bad thing I say so far
it's a good thing very mentally prepped
is Dennis LaRue in this strong for a
1,500 matchup and Game four is underway
and they're having another JUCO piano
and they're both trying to play quickly
and I get said I think white I mean I
think dennis is playing very good I
think
God shows chances lie amor you know in
the scrambles and the time factor and
everything else but so far
dennis is very sharp he needs to just
trust himself a little bit more and once
again they're playing a very slow gioco
piano but now black is going for the
bishop chief or plan which I like a
little bit less because then you can
just play h3 and if Bishop h5 now you
can go rookie one night of 193 and I
think actually you know Michael is
overthinking at this time he should have
played the plan with Bishop e6 may be
prepared with rook e8 to avoid the
double points but this is just good for
white knight of 193 is just good for
white the bishop becomes kind of off off
the mark and then white will just play
for 9h 495 once the bishop moves and
here white is already doing quite well
so black is trying to go King h8 f5 but
I don't think you'll have that much time
93 needs to be played quickly although
there is a move g4 and then 93 but okay
it's this makes sense as well okay so it
takes but now Queen takes is already
very comfortable for white very
comfortable Queen f6 okay so he's trying
to get Queens off which it tries to get
rid of some attack now I would play
probably keep the Queen okay night of
five is a good move playing for an
attack Queen g3 might be an idea and
then maybe rook f1 and king h1 and
enough for opening up their file 97 is
about to be played probably and that
looks like a good move trying to
neutralize that night
remember everyone Michael must win this
to force an Armageddon
Denis just needs to draw and he wins the
match
yeah but of course in blitz it's very
hard to think about it like this no play
for win or not especially not at this
level I'm speaking mathematics yeah yeah
it is very different
hey it's gaming five it's not even an
increment or delay here but then as I
can sense he's a little bit intense and
Michael is a bit more relaxed he's just
take yes move by move game by game
really Pokemon says yeah Michael is
chill g4 very interesting night 6 of 5
GF 5 so that's why you were spending
some time you wanted to see how good
this move is it's a critical decision so
yeah it's but it's very ambitious Taco
Bell at 6 and the chat says Denis reveal
your true power the world is ready now
coin G 3 H 4 is a good plan Queen Chi 3
H 4 g5 Queen G 3 H 4 g5 white but Bishop
e3 this move I like a bit less but still
I think I like white here now F take C 3
I think I would play
opening up that F file and then yeah and
that's you know good move Quincy three
now Quinn g3 yeah simple and now look f1
h4 at 95 I don't like that move because
you know you're just best to stepping
into a tempo in the long run anyway so
that's kind of helping white because
white wanted to go Quincy 3 H 4 anyway
and he's kind of helping black chooses
plan in some ways 97 probably will be
played and now Rock f1 should be played
or h4 yeah real tough one now explain
quickly that's good I it's xa5 rook
takes of five although although it's
certainly interesting to take with a
pawn as well but I would probably take
what the rope keep the F file going
look f1 is I think a good move they take
with a cheap one interesting because he
wants to play in the G file this I like
a bit less because there's only one
weakness g7 point and I think that's
easy to guard with you know night and h7
rookin g8 this are like a bit less but
at the same time still unlike whites
position King h8 and he played it right
so you know the ideas he wants to go
route g8 and cover up g7 and I think
this is gonna be pretty solid it's gonna
be very hard for white to break through
oh but she's six I'm not sure about that
move really because then you could take
on g6 and you have their file also you
can play h4 here so I think this is a
bit risk risky but maybe not terrible
okay so you played age four
now you have to bring the knight back
now FG I think should be played Queen
takes is forced and now I wonder if you
should keep Queens probably should play
Queen h3 if I was Dennis I would
probably play Queen h3 here
he's thinking a bit too much here now
he's behind on the clock
yeah but the end game I think it's not
bad for block now I don't I don't really
like this so much for now black and you
don't like this for white for white I
mean sorry
yeah now because now in this position
black is very solid black is up on time
and white has no initiative and if he's
gonna play slower black will just run
white out of time in the endgame
the longer the endgame goes so I
definitely don't like this and here this
endgame i think is just bad for white
because black has an outside passport he
can create a passport with the G file
with the g5 Khrushchev says yeah let's
trade yeah definitely
although 94 was unnecessary than just
king of three but he has to play it
quicker he should have just played g5
Pugachev okay so he's going back now
lost a couple of time now if I was white
I'll go a 5 and then Bishop e6 fixed
that point on b7 as a weakness and then
try to attack his target okay he goes
right away now black can play a 5 which
would make sure that secures the pawns
and he found it yes that was a good move
chef c8 b6 before that's why white
should have played before
a5 that would have been very important
now I think black will win this game
because the endgame is equal ish but I
think you'll just win on time because
he's better and he can press on for a
very long time you see white has like an
extra pawn on the Queen side but you
can't use it because one of his pawns is
double in the center but black should
play g5 oh this was a terrible move eg
because now he just created white a
potential pastor in a very bad move you
know et he should have played g5 at some
point definitely do not unde of all
these bones here very serious positional
way you're saying that black created a
potential passer for white white yeah
the porn on the e-file will now don't
you know why can now try to play 5 and
even make a passport so that was a very
big now white should play Bishop g5
could move you know preparing bishop c6
and then you know at some point pushing
the pawn but the only problem is the
time still bishop c6 is a good move
now don't go a night b8y a night of
sixty-five 'if I've quickly quickly
Denis quickly yeah you see now white
gets a lot of counter place so that's
GED yep and then Bishop t5 next move
what's the time that the time station is
very bad for for for black for white
white white sorry this 55 you need to
play to stop King e6 he finds it yes
very good
he's playing good moves but he's playing
slowly and that will hurt him an end
game like this because as long as you
don't lose right away you're just gonna
get flagged here Knight a5 good move
based on ID age 5 93 and now black just
wanna porn so white eventually blundered
because of the time situation yes and
right there just like 76 seconds ticked
off right there yeah and now I would say
white is just lost you know both
positional and position wise and and
time wise publisher which is played much
quicker than game and the early middle
king is 6 is a winning move now he's
overthinking ok 93 is not so gay he
wants to go 91 I guess that's what his
ideas which is also interesting giving
up the porn for this porn which probably
also is winning okay now night sex a for
this winning night XA for Michael Knight
takes a four yes very good Bishop 8 7 9
63 yeah now white is just losing out oh
he just touched the porn now you getting
kinky 6 now
but he is not gonna you know get the
points in time he lost on time my
friends we are going to an Armageddon
with an even score as Michael pugachev
clocks out Dennis LaRue in game 4 to
score and even to all and so we're gonna
have a five minute versus four minute
Armageddon to decide the match winner I
didn't expect this two games ago Alex no
I thought there was a chance I mean you
know you never know I mean then such
matches there's always a chance even if
there were grandmasters playing it would
be possible to come back from 2-0 to
blitz games right so you know blitz is
very streakiest so once you know who
Michael won that that previous game
where Denis just overthought then I
thought there's actually a very good
chance he'll win this game okay firstly
if it's gonna go based on this floor
we're going to await the drawing of lots
for white or black now here's how it
works
white is going to have five minutes okay
there's no delay no increment in this
game White has five minutes black has
four minutes the trade-off here is black
has draws if the game is a draw then
black gets the nod and is the match
winner so that is it's time odd versus
draw odd this I tell you as far as
predictions go look at splits right but
you got a 50% chance of getting it right
but as far as predictions go I'm gonna
go with Pugachev right now because Puka
cheb has the momentum and i think dennis
is frazzled what would you say oh I
think it also depends on what color each
player gets because I think I'm pretty
sure if pugachov gets white and gets
five minutes then I'm pretty sure he's
winning the game because you know one
minute advantage and we as we see hardly
ever at this level we have draws anyway
and there's flagging right but if
somehow Dennis gets black I mean he's
solid he has an extra minute then maybe
he has a little bit of a chance to make
a comeback so I think white will be a
very big advantage in this real
again it depends on who draws the white
color I don't I don't think there was
any negotiating but perhaps if everyone
got together they would give black four
and a half minutes in this venue with
these particular players because yeah I
totally agree with you Alex on the draw
scenario but I do agree that I I kind of
like bowl by Jeff's momentum a little
bit more but certainly both players have
fair shot I think so wouldn't be
surprised by either one the YouTube chat
is lighting up right here Ryan Deering
who works here at the club says let's go
Michael
Denis must be punished for his
positional sins do you agree
positional since well I think both are
playing positional sins but you know at
the same time you know Denis you know I
think the main problem for Denis I mean
he's playing overall pretty decently but
sometimes just playing a little bit
slower and overthinking especially that
third game where he had the game under
control pretty much about to be taken
but then just started once he was down
before below a minute he was like really
overthinking things and overanalyzing
and lost on time oh and now we see
Michael has the time advantage and Denis
has draw adds I think this is
devastating news for Denis yeah I think
I think it's not good for Dennis I think
why has a 1200 blitz rated that Michael
is a huge favorite no just look at look
at those fists right this is the face
he's looking at the board very
concentrated no I I definitely now
expect Michael to oh now they're talking
they they they've said of exchanges a
few words I think but oh man hopefully
yeah there you see if you look closely
at that clock five minutes versus four
minutes right there
okay the tension was too much guys let's
stretch it off let's stretch it off
okay seventh-inning stretch it's
actually the top of the ninth staying a
little bit later no why do we 9th it's
like 12th or something already
we're hockey season yeah it's overtime
overtime yes okay so Nick risco
is making sure that everything is a go
and on our end we're we're ready to go
he's explaining the rules now I
understand that first of all this is not
a rated game Armageddon is not a rated
variant but in this time control in this
blitz an illegal move may no longer in
the game anymore it's simply a time
penalty so we mate with this craziness
we might see it but here we go Game five
of the final playoff Armageddon yeah and
this time again you know dennis is going
for a very salt set of not the Dutch but
a queen's gambit declined and he's
playing it very quickly and confident
this time which is exactly what dennis
needs to do and also I like his strategy
opening up the center simplifying the
game and getting closer to the draw I
wouldn't have played b6 so I would have
just taken twice on c4 and t4
so they're both once again knowing their
theory but you know white needs to just
keep the time advantage and you know
play you know solid you know blunder
free chess and then I think Michael
should be able to win eventually on the
clock
now I think he should take on g5 create
a night support yeah I think that's a
good move not a nice little pond but you
know potentially hanging points and
let's say now I would take on c5 also
because of bt65 the pawn on c5 is
hanging yeah and then he does that so
now pugachov has warmed up and he's
playing some good share now night he
just Hunger porn now Knight 65 just is a
porn blunder Knight 65 just winds up one
I mean is he just making sure or is it
he or she not see a he sees it Knight 65
wins the porn and he stoled one minute
and on the clock and I would say yeah
unless Michael makes some huge blunders
I would say the match is almost over
because up a pawn huge time advantage
you know now adenosine really low on
confidence and now he just needs to
basically finish him off well it's got
to feel like no this is the blunder
again Knight 67 and Bishop d6 and it
looks like tactics are definitely up his
alley Michael definitely sees tactics
very quickly I know it's going more and
more downhill for for Denison now the
blunders started creeping in he's also
probably getting a bit tired and and now
his king is falling I mean at this point
you know it's just look you see how he
just slammed the pieces there at the top
of the screen that he is very unsettled
there that's trapped under ice time
Brooks he wants a mistake though because
now black could take on a two so that
was a little bit careless but he doesn't
even see it yeah so at this point Denis
is just missing everything while for
Michael this egg overtime is helpful
because he's a young player he's like
you know energized he's like warmed up
for Denis it's already you know he was
playing I think on his last legs
unfortunately and yeah I expect white to
be able to convert this at this point
I think we're Dennis lost the match
really was Games three especially game
three was the pivotal only because that
was where pugachov was like I said are
not confident and that was where he had
him completely on the ropes but he did
not take advantage he played too slowly
too cautiously too and and then he gave
Michael new life the memento was sudden
and Michael's shoes and then the fact
that he also had to play black this game
was also definitely not in his favor so
yeah it's just not going well for black
I mean you can try to take the point
innate so you should at least try to
take the point but yeah which she does
but why can take on a six why compare
okay one it's just not looking very good
for black just get it back you get it
back Y up a pool on you're up in
exchange and you're up one minute on the
clock
Black has only two minutes left white
has three minutes left so unless white
rest completely chokes it's looking over
queen g6 now offering the Queen trade
any place it quickly and confidently and
black correctly avoids the Queen trade
but now okay technically or maybe he did
say just but now Bishop c4 I would try
to exchange them more people right
because then you have to take the road
yeah theoretically speaking yeah now
maybe blacks should go Knight 63 hoping
for some complications but then Bishop
takes c6 is winning anyways so yeah I
mean Michael's playing good chess Bishop
c4 good move Rose g8 but now you can
just take the night that blunders the
night now
well actually doesn't blunder if Bishop
takes d5 Queen takes d5 there's Queen a6
so it doesn't blunder anything okay only
played night b8 yeah now I mean almost
anything who wins Queen c7 is probably
good because then you're you know yeah
when he finds out yeah Queen c7 a very
good movie I because if Bishop takes d5
Rotex of six if rook takes d5 Queen
takes B 8 so now Bloods gonna lose more
material now you just
he lost the Queen so yeah that last game
he blundered just everything
unfortunately yeah and now the house
felons yeah I think now he will probably
resign this game that pan signals the
I'm about to resign hands signal well
actually he is playing out but maybe
hoping for a stalemate okay now he
resigned Wow Michael Pugachev takes a
breath of fresh air a little Sam
Shanklin cheer there that was that was
clutch oh man and Denis LaRue I think
we're about to see the exchange of the
bounty right here we did it in studio
last time come on Nick move out of the
way if that's what they're gonna do but
remember dennis has promised
Pugachev to powerball tickets I'm sure
his parents will enjoy that worth
potentially millions of dollars as Mike
comer would like to say and also $36
cash which is the prize for the Friday
action quads here at the st. Louis chess
club so I'm sure if it was absurd but
actually there will be worth a million
dollars I'm sure pugachov will happily
share that with the club and Dennis the
trick is you don't tell anybody you go
off the grid for a little bit Alex no
personally if I was getting a gift like
that and I would earn this much money I
would definitely share it if that would
happen so well what we're gonna do here
in just a moment we're gonna have the
players in here for post match
interviews to have the sights and the
sounds the cheers the jeers and the
tears right here in the studio Alex what
is your assessment of the match that we
saw here today all is a great fighting
match I really enjoy covering it this
very interesting play both very good
fighting players and I would say yeah I
mean they played very decent chests
considering it was blitz considering
their level they played they were very
well prepared they came here to play
they came to here to fight sure there
were mistakes but I think yeah it was
much better than I expected actually the
quality so I think what we'll do here
since you've got all the the games up
you want to analyze a little bit with
the players we could do that sure we'll
we'll get to that once we have the
player
down here and I will get them in here
but it's been a really fun
blitz bounty - and it's Owen -
unfortunately for Dennis LaRue who is
just having his bank broke and I hear
some shouting outside the studio and it
might be Dennis I don't know might be
angry well thank you for joining us on
the show thus far interview still to
come here on our broadcast and remember
this show is streaming live it started
at 5:30 p.m. Central Time but for
historical value will be uploading it in
HD later this evening or tomorrow so you
can watch it in glorious HD and see all
of my acne on my face is just really
great you can't miss it so I'm wondering
who is next for Dennis LaRue oh well I
mean I'm not too familiar with like the
young and up-and-coming players here in
st. Louis but I'm sure like there are
many matches that I think will be good I
mean maybe he'll try to revenge
I can't polish off but maybe some
up-and-coming another up-and-coming
young player so I'm not I'm not exactly
sure but we'll see I mean I I'm just not
familiar with the local players that
might well we've got we've got great
contenders like Julian Pro Lake Oh if
dennis is glutton for punishment you can
go even stronger no but Julian is a
master right 2,300 or something yeah but
wouldn't it be fun well then it should
be time odds or something hey dennis is
a trooper man I'll tell you so I think
we have interviews just about ready
outside so if we are let's just take a
look at the boardroom if we can Danny
just let me know where we are there we
go
a that over the shoulder shot maybe you
were going to play against Dennis do you
think I should challenge him
maybe yeah well alright fans we'll be
back in just a moment with our first of
two interviews don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right welcome Dennis thanks for
coming thanks for being a good sport so
yes so I thought you know you're playing
very well
in the beginning you came out of the
gate very strong you were you know as
you were planning you were playing good
chess you were not blundering you were
playing quickly and you were out playing
your opponents and seeing a lot of the
tactics so where did you think it
started going home for you um once I
started winning I got a little
overconfident Alex and I didn't manage
my time as carefully in the third game
and I think I still had a playable
position in that stone wall that I
played but I just flagged I'm old and
slow yeah that's that's where I thought
actually the game took a turn for the
worse because you see in this game yeah
you were actually playing very no sir
that's the wrong game this this disc
this game yes so in this game you were
actually playing very good chess you
know you're out playing your opponent he
went for some slightly dubious it's
correct to take with very much you can
also take with a cheap one but probably
he should not take on d5 you should
probably go here but you know he did
this there's no point of analyzing the
Blitz game too much Bishop h6 probably
unnecessary but it was a hope for a
little trick after this 95 right so rook
e8 a 95 97 h4 yeah and here I saw that
you can do this this and then 94 and
then threatening this but you know the
way you played was or was good to I mean
it's hard to see everything and in blitz
and by the way a quick question for you
what would you do if there's Bishop
takes e4 would happen what would you do
then
what am i yeah there's some sort of
trick here yeah because of de there's
quincy for just to show the fans King h8
night of 7 so in that case it would be
very important to do this smoke first
and then after this you're out of all
the tactical danger I I was not aware of
this tactic so I would have yeah I
would've had to hope that I would find
it yeah but otherwise yeah 94 was
probably a mistake because actually you
were able to win the porn and he put the
king also in a very dubious Square and
yeah I think here you were still playing
very good chefs but just maybe you know
trying to be a bit too perfect taking a
little bit too much time yeah and that's
kind of where the game slipped away for
you yeah de Fora thought was interesting
but it was a bit complicated maybe it
was better to just bring the rope back
first get all your development in and
only then go for a t4 just just to make
your life simpler you know in endless
before he actually played check yeah now
you have to calculate a lot I thought
there should be six you didn't play
because of this one right probably yes
but then I think GTX III is coming and
then Queen d2 and yeah but you know I
even after this you're doing very well
but I think this is where you started
spending really it took a lot of time
and this move and this is where you know
unfortunately you know it was like you
know one of the things I tell my
students is you almost always want to
avoid spending more than half your
remaining time so if you have one minute
left you don't want to spend 30 seconds
on a move unless you absolutely have to
and this was probably where the game
slipped away from you and then it was
kind of hard to come back and then
alrighty
last game you know not Armageddon game
but the last game that was no not this
game one second now let me find it this
game maybe yeah this this one yes so
this game I thought you again you are
you're actually outplayed your opponent
and he decided to improve with Bishop
core would improve the description for
Bishop h5 but in fact this is just very
comfortable for you but you know some
questions for you
year g4 was very interesting by the way
very interesting for the Blitz not
normal but this is probably not a great
move for a g4 g4 is very interesting I
wouldn't have played it but it was
probably good practical wise for blitz
to seem like opposed a few problems yeah
and here I would not have gone Bishop
III I would probably I was thinking all
along go here age 45 and just you know
he has hook on h6 and just go for a
direct attack
so you went here takes takes Knight g5
yeah Knight g5 wasn't very good because
it helped your you know h4 you plan
right and here I thought you should
definitely take with the rook because
then you're going broke f1 h for g5 and
this is very weak this is like a much
easier point to target I think then I
just played I took yeah that was a
little bit too creative because now the
Queen on of six actually locates
everything very nicely and it's hard to
get anything in and suddenly here he was
playing very quickly he was getting up
in time I don't think g6 was a good move
I thought he should just go rogue g8
Knight h7 and keep solid I couldn't
figure out how to recapture on that
fight right yeah
this is actually still very good but I
think where you really made your mistake
especially given the time situation was
taking on g6 because you basically went
for from a very promising attack where
you could have hoped to mating him and
really just played for initiative so go
into the endgame where you're down 30
seconds and then you have a good chance
of being flat in an endgame like that
right so that was probably I think my
decision-making process was backwards
right and there was also a very
interesting moment I wanted to point out
yeah you should have played a five
fixing the sport and then only done this
because then this would come with a lot
more venom and this would be I think
very unpleasant for your opponent to
deal with like it's the only way he can
defend this looks like 98 97 but this
would be a very hard maneuver obviously
for him to find especially in blitz and
I think you have a very good chance of
winning the game that if I Percy I gotta
fix the pawn a 5 you probably gotta go
something like this and then you can
actually win the game here by attacking
the points just make sense but you know
Bishop e6 was a bit too straightforward
and easily defended he played a five and
now it was just very solved for him and
you know here he still made a very bad
decision of giving you undone your pawns
and giving you counter play he should
just play g6 g5 and then just basically
he could flag you here because you don't
have any active play and he can just
maneuver all day long and even
objectively it's bad but even after this
it was at this point you were low on
time and it was just very hard to to
play from this point on it he kept his
composure and and then I think yeah it
was a very bad luck for you or maybe not
bad luck I mean who was the one choosing
the clock I mean the color the color the
coin sauce went to which one it was
they we leaded TD do it so it went yeah
it went to you know a favored Michael
got widened because of that yeah and
that was a little bit bad luck for you I
thought because I thought you for you to
have the best chance in this time
control you being on the other side of
the army yeah because you know you you
needed the white admitted initiative one
extra minute and I need and all that
yeah and unfortunately seemed like you
know he was just as just as he was
getting momentum he was becoming sharper
and sharper it seems like that last game
you were just getting a bit tired you
know pieces start you know for the first
four games you were playing very good
when it came to you know not blundering
but unfortunate last game all the pieces
just you know we're falling and like a
house of cards and the game of dominoes
exactly unfortunately it was a bad break
for you and I had fun and it was a great
privilege to have you doing commentary
sounds good but I mean so now
unfortunately you're all in - so where
do you go from here from this point on
down yeah I know this is I heard been
rehearsing this question with you on you
go to a place where you can just cry
quietly in the dark Alex that's where
I'm going
well I hope you'll be back tomorrow in
good mood again I'm sure that you know
you've played you know pretty good
chests today actually I was actually
very impressed you're seeing a lot of
good tactics you know Europe knew the
openings very well you you were very
well prepared and I'm sure you know
things will go even better for you
next time I think sure next time you
know you'll probably at some point win
one of these matches and let's hope so
let's hope so i yeah I may never do it
again we'll see if the public demands it
we'll do another one but this was this
was a concession for the Scholastic's
crowd Michael and Jacob really wanted
well Michael fought very hard and then
then you know I you know as as the match
kept going he was only getting seems
sharper he was a different Michael than
round three I thought I had broke him
but he he he came back and hurt me yeah
well thanks for coming in again for
having me yeah sure sure thing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so we're here with the winner of
the event michael pugachov
so congratulations thank you and a great
comeback we'll have to call you come
back kick kids from this point on so um
what was so after you know you had a
very difficult start you know first two
games could have gone either away but
they didn't go your way so what was your
mentality after the first two games like
to you know start your comeback trail
yeah I just tried to stay calm and just
focus on one game at a time
sounds like an excellent advice so in
the first game it looks like you know
you're playing quite well actually we
don't have the whole game but then it
looks like this this one move f5 that
really hurt you where it looks like yeah
you know maybe you miscounted otherwise
you were doing very well yeah second
game let me see where is that second
game yeah this was a second game yeah
second game what do you think were the
main critical moments in this game Oh
besides the very end which was a bit
unlucky but I think the critical moments
were just I had to stay like my time was
running low and I wasn't really focusing
on that so that's why I think I lost the
first two games but then I tried to
speed it up in the beginning to have
time to think throughout the game
yeah and that was a very good choice now
I noticed that you know in the last game
you decided to switch and so Bishop g4
plan yeah was there a reason did you
think that you did not get a good
opening in this position in this game no
I felt like I did I just my bishop
wasn't really active so in that game so
I just wanted to make sure I did the
opposite of that ya know because I think
there should be six is actually more of
the main plan in this kind of position
maybe it's better to play rook e8 and
then try to go Bishop e6 and sometimes
take back with the rook as long as
there's no fork you know usually you
bring the bishop out of the way first
yeah because you know in the last game I
think your bishop was actually in you
know a bit of trouble you ended up
having to and this was kind of unopposed
but yeah I think the opening was fine
game for you actually I think you played
quite well I think they're just the
Bishop a7 when you had to take back with
the rook this is where you kind of you
know he got the initiative and then you
fought back very well and then okay when
there's fifteen seconds each anything
can happen
yeah but when did you think was the
critical moment when you thought okay
now I can ruin this match you know now
it's like momentum is on my side after
the after the third game when I won with
Dennis on time pressure I'm like if I do
this same strategy then maybe that'll
work again
yeah and that's also what I thought
because that's where I think he was a
little bit unsure of himself he was
taking a little bit too much time in the
last part of the game and that's where I
thought you know now you'll have the
momentum now you're playing more
confidently and then things can go very
well
and and what do you think you was your
favorite game today my favorite game cuz
I think the third game because it was a
turning point
third game yes so which yeah so third
game was actually a very interesting one
let's let's bring that third game so
where do you think you know the last
position you know you won on time but
it's probably lost freedom huh but where
do you think were some critical moments
in that game like which moves were you
most happy with this was always planning
to play rip d1 but I think after I got
my King day 2 and Denis thought that if
he just took the rook on d1 he'd be up a
rope but then I just take back in it oh
yeah I remember that moment where you
win that Queen but at that point he was
ready yeah but I think here it was kind
of a tough position for you so I think
as far as I know it's better not to take
cont e5 it's better to go here yeah and
yeah you went for a very ambitious
strategy here with what going for attack
it's very good yeah maybe he didn't
react the best way but you know
nevertheless you know it all worked out
and you ended up winning probably here
you should just go h5 straight away
without Knight 64 but in any event
things worked very well and what do you
think the main critical moments and in
in the in this game were game 4
yes why why are we doing this now
alright congratulations Michael thank
you thirty-six bucks good good thank you
for that so yeah I think here I was a
bit surprised here that you know I
thought 95 was maybe unnecessary because
it forces Queen g3 h4 anyway but I
thought you should take what with the
rook I was very surprised didn't that
would have been pressure but I think
once you got to that end game yeah yeah
well he also should probably keep Queens
on the board because hurricane is a bit
weak but once you got to endgame I
thought yeah he's he's gonna struggle
here because he was down on time and
your position is easier I feel like and
here I think there is one thing he
should have tried to do he should try to
play a5 with the idea of going Bishop e6
and trying to attack these then you have
to play 98 97 but that's the hard i
maneuvered to find it in blitz certainly
but once he did this you know now I
think you're very much in control yeah
and here I was a bit surprised by one
decision why did you decide to take this
and straighten out his pawns and give
them it was just fixing his pawns in
giving you a better position but I think
we're just playing because it's time
yeah yeah I think g5 you know then it's
very simple okay it's maybe not winning
but like on time you're gonna win easily
yes you could just move yeah and then on
the last game I think it was a very good
good for you that you got the white
pieces because there were no drawers in
this match that all draw is very
unlikely anyway and having five minutes
against four when Denis was struggling
with time was a huge advantage in the
last game you just played very well you
know you took everything that was given
to you played excellent positional game
and and then all his pieces started
falling and it seemed like you were just
when he was you know getting tired
you were just heating up yeah he's
getting the momentum and at that point I
knew that you would be a
favor them so congratulations so so how
do you how does this feel you know it
feels good because I came back from two
nothing deficit mm-hmm so yeah shows
that you're great a fighter with a
straight character and you know let's
hope you know many more big wins for you
in your future career is still very
young player hopefully you know more
great things from you in the future
hopefully we'll see you at some point
again in the studio hopeful already in a
big tournament like an orb tournament or
something like that
thank you all right good luck thanks for
coming thank you so much so that was
[Music]
[Music]
you know Dennis being a great sportsman
had no qualms about presenting the
Powerball in a $36 and we saw Michael
Pugachev collect the bounty so we want
to thank everybody for joining us here
for blitz bounty number two in the
Dennis LaRue era but I'd like to tell
you about some upcoming events here at
the st. Louis chess club you know
there's always something new and coming
up next we have the US on us chess
champs calm we have the summer chess
classic and you know the first summer
chess classic last year was just an
amazing event this year it's gonna be a
little bit different because
traditionally these classic events are
ten players single round robins now
we're going to have three six player
double round-robin events and for the
first time I'd like to relay to you the
competitors in Group A the strongest
group at the summer chess Classic which
begins on June 18th from the bottom up
grandmasters Jeffrey Zhang daro spirits
Liam Lee Gawain Jones former US Champion
Sam Shanklin and from Poland young
Kristoff Duda this is the strongest
classic event ever one of the seasonal
classics here at the st. Louis chess
club I'm really looking forward to that
it begins on June 18th that's round
number one of 10 June 18th your host for
that event will be grandmaster jessie
cry and young Caleb Denby that's gonna
be an amazing event Alex looking forward
to it yeah very much so I'll definitely
be happy to look over the games no
definitely gonna be a lot of instructive
value there you know and potentially
some of these guys are my future
competitors that hopefully your
championship right and of course for the
entire fields check out us chest champs
calm but guess what that's not all it's
overlapping with another event and it's
a big one it's Croatia
grand chest or the second leg of the
2019 grand chest tour all
all 12 competitors in this year's event
this year's tour will be in Croatia for
the first event there in the GCT they'll
be playing classical 11 rounds and that
begins also in June slight overlap with
the summer chess classic for more
information on that and the grand chest
or standings because we've already been
to Cote d'Ivoire check out Grantchester
dot-com and we hope to be presenting an
alternate language broadcast to you as
well more anthem for more information on
that upcoming I should say and then a
little bit later on in July another
first here at the st. Louis chess club
we have the u.s. juniors the u.s. girls
and now the 2019 u.s. Senior
Championship the senior closed event
it's a first time ever who will be the
first u.s. senior clothes champion that
all begins on July 10th with three
different events in one broadcast this
is the first time ever at the st. Louis
Chess Club we will be presenting three
simultaneous events talk about overload
Alex yeah that's so that's great stuff I
mean I'm looking forward to seeing the
senior tournament I'm just you know very
curious you know it's it's gonna be like
US Championships 15 years ago or
something indeed and that event will be
actually the highest-rated of the three
so we'll probably end up giving that top
billing so there's so much yet to come
here in the summer of chess and that
called a year chess here at the st.
Louis chess club we're gonna wrap things
up here for blitz bounty - thank you for
joining us this event was produced by
the world's greatest production B team
we have Danny Machuca the technical
director Isaac's France is graphics and
audio and I want to thank you all for
joining us of course the great sportsman
themselves Dennis LaRue our runner-up
and our blitz bounty 2 champion michael
Pugachev he gets the $36 he gets the two
Powerball tickets potentially worth
millions according to Mike comer for
Grandmaster Alexander Linderman
my name is Ben Simon until next time we
say so long from the show-me-state
[Music]
[Music]